كيف تفهم هذا التصعيد المتزايد لاسرائيل
في الضفه
الغربيه صباح الخير لك ولل المشاهدين يعني
واضح انه ما يحدث في الضف وتحديدا في
مدينه القدس هو ياتي يعني اي انسجاما مع
مشروع جماعات الهيكل والصهيونيه الدينيه
الاستغلال الوضع الحالي في غزه والاهتمام
الدولي في غزه ل هندسه ال الواقع بضف و
ومدينه القدس بما ينسجم مع رؤى ومشروع
الصهيونيه الدينيه الذاهب باتجاهين
الاتجاه الاول ما يخص مدينه القدس و
المسجد الاقصى
وتقليص صلاحيات ودور الاوقاف الاسلاميه
الاردنيه
والفلسطينيه الى حده
الادنى
ثم قطع شوط كبير في موضوع تهويد م مدينه
القدس بالضافه الغربيه الامور تسير بنفس
الموضوع ولكن باتجاهين
الامني و والاستيطان والاثنين يعني يصبان
في في في في نفس الهدف وهو تح تجميع
التجمعات الفلسطينيه في المناطق المسماه
الف وباء في مناطق محصوره محدده حيث 90%
من الشعب الفلسطيني بالضفه موجودين في
منطقه اي وبي في ظل قيام ميليشيات
المستوطنات منذ اليوم الاول للحرب الحاليه
بحملات قمع وارهاب ضد عشرات البلدات
والقرى والتجمعات الفلسطينيه الموجوده في
المناطق التي ت تسمى مناطق جيم لاجبارهم
على الرحيل باتجاه مناطق الف وباء وحينها
تكون اسرائيل قد استطاعت ان يعني تهندس
الوضع الاخير للضفه الغربيه بحيث الوصول
الى مشروع من العشرات الكانتونات
الفلسطينيه
بالضفه المتناثره غير المتصله الموجوده في
بحر كبير من السيطره الامنيه والعسكريه
والاستيطان الاسرائيليه
ومربوطه بطرق التفافه بحيث يتم ربط كل
التجمعات الاسرائيليه بالضفه و وبالداخل
مع بعضها بينما يتم تفكيك كل التجمعات
الفلسطينيه جغرافيا و ومجتمعيا وسياسيا
وصولا الى تفكيك حتى السلطه بشكلها المركز
الحالي برام الله وتقسيمها الى سلطات كل
منطقه ب بمنظومات الاداريه والخدمات هي
الوظيفيه بما ينسجم مع المشروع الاسرائيلي
باتجاه تفكيك الضفه الغربيه و خلق واقع
يستحيل في اقامه اي كيان فلسطيني مستق هذه
تحركات يمكن ان تؤدي الى فتح جبهه في
الطفه الغربيه هل اسرائيل معنيه بذلك فعلا
في ظل كل المشاكل المرتبطه بحربها في غزه
والجبهه الشماليه
ايضا يعني هنالك تيارين داخل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالو الوقت الحالي تيار اي
يقود التيار الامني والمخابرات والجيش
والذي يعمل باتجاه يعني تحييد الضفه
الغربيه و يعني تقليل حده الاحتكاك
وتحديدا تخفيف حده يعني ممارسات
المستوطنين ل عدم يعني اشعال جبهه
الضفه مجددا ولكن بالنهايه الذي يؤثر
اليوم هو تيار اليمين الديني المستوطنين
جماعه بن كفير وجماعه سموتريتش الذين يعني
اصبح لهم الكثير من الحضور والتاييد داخل
المؤسسات الامنيه هؤلاء يرون انه مصلحتهم
استمرار حاله الاشتباك التي تخدم مشروعهم
حزبيا انتخابيا سياسيا عقائديا باطاله و
وديمومته مع الفلسطينيين على قاعده انه
الاشتباك مع الفلسطينيين يؤدي
الى انحراف كبير بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي
باتجاه اليمين وتحديدا اليمين الديني ثم
ايصال الفلسطيني الى الى واقع اما ان يسلم
واما ان ان يهاجر وهذا يعني ترجمه لمشروع
الحسم الذي اعلن عنه بيتسل ايس مترش في
العام 2017 وواضح تماما انه نتيجه ضعف
بنيامين نتنياهو وحش لهم ذهب كثيرا
نتنياهو من اجل ارضائهم وترجمه هذا
المشروع والذي يعني يتابع ما يحدث بالضفه
من من من من تركيبه ديموغرافيه للمستوطنين
وهذا الواقع الجغرافي الطوبوغرافي الذي مر
بتغيرات سريعه بالسنوات القليله الماضيه
يصل الى الى الى قناعه ان مشروع الصهيونيه
الدينيه يسير على قدم مساق بالضفه الغربيه
والذي توج في في الاول من نوفمبر الماضي
في ذروه الحرب بتشكيل لجنه بالكنيست والتي
كانت لاول مره بتاريخ اسرائيل ان تشكل
لجنه بالكنيست الاسرائيلي مسؤوله عن الضفه
الغربيه وان يعين على راس المستوطن سفي
سوكوت عضو الكنيست من جماعه بن كفير
مسؤولا عن عن عن هذا اللج هذا اللجنه
مضمونها هو ترجمه و ورعايه والاشراف على
مشروع الصهيونيه الدينيه الذاهب باتجاه ضم
الحد الاقصى من اراضي الضفه الغربيه
وتفريغ منطقه سي من من من الوجود
الفلسطيني فيها والذي يصل الى حوالي
350,000 فلسطيني موجودين موزعين بهذه
المناطق وحشرهم بالكونات التي كانت تسمى
مناطق اي وبي مقدمه ل عمليه الضم لما تبقى
من الضفه الغربيه بال والتي تشكل اكثر من
60% وبالمناسبه مجرد مجرد تشكيل لجنه
بالكنيست لاداره شؤون الضفه الغربيه هذا
يعني ان الضفه الغربيه باتت تعامل كما
تعامل يعني مدن داخل داخل داخل اسرائيل
وخاصه انه بالقانون الدولي المناطق
المحتله ي يتم الاشراف عليها وادارتها من
قبل القائد العسكري الاحتلالي للمنطقه
المحتله لاول مره بتاريخ اسرائيل تشكل هذه
اللجنه وهذا الموضوع يعني كان بمثابه
استغلال للوضع الحالي والانشغال الفلسطيني
والاقليمي
والدولي بما يحدث في في غزه شكرا لك عادل
شديد الباحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
كنت معنا من
الخليل